Bonjour à tous,
Aujourd'hui on va parler d'une
des expériences
les plus dingues de la mécanique quantique,
une expérience bizarrement, très peu connue
du grand public
et qui nous montre un truc incroyable
sur la nature profonde de la réalité
qui nous entoure.
En mécanique quantique, il y a une idée
centrale mais étrange,
celle qui dit que les objets quantiques
puissent être dans des états superposés.
Prenons l'exemple de l'atome d'hydrogène,
un seul proton avec un électron
dont on s'imaginerait
qu'il lui tourne autour,
un peu comme une planète.
Eh bien d'après la mécanique quantique
l'électron ne serait pas localisé
de façon précise quelque part
sur une trajectoire,
mais il serait plutôt dans une superposition
de plein de positions possibles,
un peu comme s'il était partout à la fois
autour du proton
ou plutôt nulle part en particulier.
La seule chose que la mécanique quantique
nous décrive
c'est la probabilité de présence de
l'électron en chacun des points
qui correspond à la probabilité
de le trouver ici ou là
si on fait une mesure pour essayer
de le localiser,
mais si on ne fait pas de mesure,
l'électron reste dans un état superposé
sans localisation bien définie.
Autre exemple, en mécanique quantique
certaines particules possèdent
une propriété qu'on appelle le spin
et qui, pour simplifier, peut être vue
comme une petite aimantation
orientée soit vers le haut,
soit vers le bas,
soit dans une superposition des deux,
mais si on essaye de mesurer ce spin,
on ne verra jamais de superpositions
on trouvera toujours l'une des deux
réponses: haut ou bas,
mais avec, par exemple 50 % de probabilités
pour chacune.
Cette notion de superposition d'états et de
résultats de mesure probabilistes
qui dépendrait du hasard, ça paraît assez
difficile à se représenter pour nous.
Ça n'arrive jamais dans notre quotidien,
les objets qui nous entourent sont
toujours quelque part
avec une orientation bien définie,
ils ne sont pas à la fois
à l'endroit et à l'envers, ou localisés
un peu partout dans l'espace.
Le physicien Erwin Schrödinger, un des
fondateurs de la mécanique quantique
n'aimait d'ailleurs pas trop cette idée
de superposition,
et c'est pour illustrer son trouble
qu'il a imaginé
sa fameuse expérience de pensée du chat.
Je pense que vous la connaissez,
il s'agit de mettre un chat dans une boîte
à côté d'un dispositif destiné à le tuer
et qui est déclenché par un système quantique
dans un état superposé.
Si on en croit la mécanique quantique,
dans la boîte,
le chat serait dans un état superposé
donc à la fois mort et vivant.
Du moins tant qu'on n'ouvre pas la boîte,
puisque c'est le fait de regarder
à l'intérieur
qui forcerait, en quelque sorte,
le chat à se matérialiser
soit dans l'état vraiment vivant
soit dans l'état vraiment mort.
Généralement quand on rencontre
cette idée de superposition d'états,
on a envie de penser comme Schrödinger
on se dit que ça n'est pas réellement
possible,
un chat est mort ou vivant mais
pas les deux à la fois,
et donc ça doit être pareil par exemple
dans l'atome d'hydrogène.
On a envie de penser que l'électron est
toujours quelque part en particulier,
pas partout à la fois autour du proton.
À la limite ce qu'on peut très bien admettre
c'est qu'on ignore son état exact.
Si vous avez un chat dans une boîte, tant
qu'on n'a pas ouvert la boîte
on ne sait effectivement pas
s'il est mort ou vivant,
on peut dire que, de notre point de vue
il est statistiquement à la fois
mort et vivant,
mais dans ce cas ce serait juste un
effet de notre ignorance,
en réalité, dans la boîte, le chat,
il serait véritablement
soit l'un soit l'autre, et le fait
d'ouvrir la boîte
ne ferait que révéler son véritable état,
qu'il a toujours eu.
C'est un peu comme quand je tire
à pile ou face,
tant que je n'ai pas retiré ma main, on
peut dire qu'il y a 50% de chances
qu'elle soit sur pile, 50% sur face.
On peut pour faire certains calculs,
décrire la pièce comme un mélange
statistique de 50% pile 50% face,
mais en réalité sous ma main elle est bien
dans un des deux états
et quand je retire ma main
je révèle lequel,
il n'y a pas réellement de superposition
d'états de la pièce,
c'est juste que moi je n'ai initialement
pas toute l'information.
Intuitivement la mécanique quantique
ça devrait être pareil,
chaque fois qu'on parle d'états qui sont
des superpositions,
chaque fois qu'on utilise des
probabilités de présence,
eh ben on se dit que c'est juste une manière
de quantifier notre ignorance
des états exacts.
L'électron serait finalement toujours
quelque part
et le fait de le mesurer ne ferait
que révéler sa position réelle.
Bon c'est en tout cas ce que Schrödinger
pensait.
Et c'est ce qu'Einstein pensait également,
pour lui la réalité doit avoir une
existence objective et cette histoire
de superposition quantique n'était qu'une
description mathématique incomplète
pour masquer notre ignorance de
l'état réel des choses.
Alors tous ces débats sur la nature
de la réalité quantique
ont commencé dans les années 1920 - 1930,
dès l'époque des premières formulations
de la mécanique quantique.
Mais près d'un siècle plus tard
on y voit un peu plus clair
sur ces questions fondamentales
et on sait que la réalité des choses est plus
tordue que ce que croyait Schrödinger
et pas vraiment non plus comme
l'espérait Einstein,
et si on le sait c'est notamment grâce
à un certain nombre d'expériences
extrêmement troublantes comme celle que
je vais vous décrire aujourd'hui.
Cette expérience a été proposée par le
physicien Lucien Hardy en 1993
et réalisée quelques années plus tard,
en utilisant
un dispositif à base de laser,
de filtres polariseur et de détecteurs
de photons,
mais expliquer avec des photons
ça n'est pas forcément
très immédiat de se rendre compte de son
caractère très perturbant.
Alors je vais l'expliquer avec des gâteaux.
Imaginez une cuisine, dans une pièce
complètement fermée
avec un cuisinier à l'intérieur
qui fait des gâteaux.
À l'extérieur deux tapis roulants
proviennent de la cuisine
et, à intervalles réguliers, disons
toutes les dix secondes,
deux gâteaux sortent de façon simultanée,
un sur chaque tapis.
Alors à priori on n'a pas de raison
de penser
que les gâteaux soient identiques, simplement
ils sortent par paire, comme ça.
À l'extrémité de chaque tapis roulant
on a placé un opérateur
chargé de tester les gâteaux
et il y a deux tests possibles.
Le premier test c'est tout simplement de
manger le gâteau
pour voir s'il est bon ou pas.
On va supposer que c'est un truc
objectif qui n'a pas d'ambiguïté,
chaque gâteau est soit clairement bon,
soit clairement mauvais.
Le second test possible c'est de mettre
le gâteau dans une machine
qui va analyser sa teneur en magnésium,
et on va supposer que là aussi,
il n'y a que deux réponses possibles
soit le gâteau contient du magnésium,
soit il n'en contient pas,
et notons qu'a priori on a pas d'hypothèse
sur le rôle possible du magnésium
et son impact éventuel
sur le goût du gâteau, on n'en sait rien,
la seule contrainte du dispositif c'est que
quand un gâteau arrive
chaque opérateur doit choisir lequel
des deux tests il veut faire,
soit il mange le gâteau
et dans ce cas
il ne peut plus l'analyser dans la
machine,
soit il l'analyse mais alors il
n'est plus mangeable.
Pour faire ce choix, on va dire
qu'à chaque gâteau qui se présente à lui,
chaque opérateur tire à pile ou face
pour déterminer quel test effectuer,
et ensuite il enregistre le résultat,
bon ou mauvais s'il l'a mangé,
magnésium ou pas de magnésium
s'il l'a analysé dans la machine.
Et à chaque paire de gâteau on recommence.
Un seul test possible de chaque côté, chaque
opérateur tire au hasard
et ne fera donc pas forcément le même test
que son homologue.
Après avoir fait ça pendant
un bon moment
disons, quelques milliers
de paires de gâteaux,
chaque opérateur a pu remarquer que
certains de ces gâteaux étaient bons,
d'autres mauvais, que certains contenaient
du magnésium et d'autres pas,
rien d'extraordinaire.
Et ensuite ils décident de se retrouver et
de comparer leurs résultats
en regardant les paires de gâteaux
qui sont sortis ensemble de la cuisine.
Alors pour chaque paire il y a
trois possibilités
soit les opérateurs ont tous les deux
mangé leur gâteau
soit ils l'ont tous les deux analysé
pour le magnésium,
soit l'un a analysé le magnésium de son gâteau
tandis que l'autre a mangé le sien.
alors commençons par regarder les résultats
qu'ils ont obtenus dans ce cas-là.
Celui où ils ont chacun réalisé
un test différent,
ils comparent leurs notes et là
ils s'aperçoivent
d'un truc assez remarquable:
si l'opérateur de gauche a analysé
le magnésium
et a trouvé qu'il y en avait
alors l'opérateur de droite a toujours
trouvé que son gâteau à lui était bon,
toujours, et pareil quand les analyses
ont été faites dans l'autre sens
si celui de droite a trouvé du magnésium
dans son gâteau
celui de gauche a systématiquement
trouvé que le sien était bon.
OK alors pourquoi pas, on ne sait pas
ce qui se passe dans la cuisine
et comment sont fabriqués ces gâteaux,
on pourrait essayer d'émettre des hypothèses
qui expliqueraient cette corrélation
mais pas besoin pour l'instant, on va
s'en tenir simplement aux résultats.
Quand l'un des deux gâteaux contient
du magnésium alors l'autre est bon.
Regardons maintenant les chiffres quand
les opérateurs ont tous les deux analysé
le magnésium dans leurs gâteaux respectifs,
et bien là on trouve tous les cas
de figures,
parfois aucun des deux gâteaux
n'en contenait
parfois un seul des deux et parfois
les deux en contenaient.
Le seul chiffre important pour nous
est celui ci:
dans 9 % des cas les deux gâteaux de la paire
contenaient du magnésium.
OK très bien, maintenant regardons
le dernier cas
celui où les deux opérateurs
ont mangé leur gâteau.
Eh bien, je vous pose la question
suivante:
à votre avis dans quel pourcentage des cas
auront-ils trouvé que les deux gâteaux
étaient bons?
Je répète ce qu'on sait:
quand les deux analysent leurs gâteaux
dans la machine,
dans 9 % des cas ils trouvent tous deux
du magnésium,
et quand l'un analyse et l'autre mange,
si l'un contient du magnésium
alors systématiquement l'autre
gâteaux est bon.
Question donc: quand les deux mangent
leur gâteau,
dans quel pourcentage des cas
les deux gâteaux sont ils bons?
Je vous laisse réfléchir,
prenez un peu de temps,
mettez sur pause si vous voulez.
Alors certains d'entre vous auront
certainement répondu 9%.
Bah oui, dans 9 % des cas les deux
gâteaux ont du magnésium
or quand l'un a du magnésium l'autre
est forcément bon et réciproquement.
Donc ça doit faire 9 % de cas où les
deux sont bons.
Ça semble assez logique, j'ai quand même voulu
poser la question à quelques amis.
– D'après mes calculs si je ne me suis pas
planté on peut dire
qu'il y à au moins 9 % de chances que les
deux gâteaux soient bons au même moment.
– On va dire que la réponse est entre 9 %
et 100 % ce qui est un grand intervalle!
– Eh oui, comme eux il y en a peut-être
parmi vous qui ont regardé les choses
de plus près et conclut que la réponse
était AU MOINS 9%
car en plus des cas où les deux ont du
magnésium,
il peut peut-être y avoir d'autres cas
où les deux gâteaux sont bons,
même sans magnésium,
on n'a pas les données qui permettraient
de donner une réponse précise,
mais la seule chose qu'on peut conclure
avec certitude
c'est que c'est au minimum 9% et peut-être
plus.
Et maintenant si je vous dis que quand
nos deux opérateurs
comparent leurs résultats,
ils se rendent compte
que la réponse est ZÉRO.
Quand tous les deux ont mangé
leur gâteau respectif,
jamais les deux gâteaux n'ont été bons
en même temps, jamais!
Surprenant comme résultat d'expérience
non?
Voire carrément impossible, prenons
un de ces cas où
les deux gâteaux ont du magnésium,
ça arrive dans 9 % des paires,
pour lesquelles on a fait l'analyse des
deux côtés,
les gâteaux arrivent au bout du tapis roulant,
si on les analyse tous les deux,
on sait qu'on trouve qu'ils ont chacun
du magnésium
mais si à droite l'opérateur l'avait mangé
à la place,
il aurait forcément trouvé qu'il était bon,
puisqu'on l'a dit, chaque fois qu'on a
du magnésium d'un côté,
si de l'autre côté on mange le gâteau,
alors il sera bon.
Donc le gâteau de droite il est forcément
bon en plus de contenir du magnésium
mais symétriquement si celui de gauche
avait mangé le sien,
vu que celui de droite a du magnésium,
on aurait aussi trouvé qu'il était bon,
donc les deux gâteaux sont tous les deux bons,
en plus de contenir du magnésium.
Donc cette paire de gâteaux là,
si on les avait tous les deux mangés
au lieu d'analyser le magnésium,
on aurait forcément trouvé qu'ils
étaient tous les deux bons,
alors c'est pas possible qu'en ayant testé
des milliers de paires de gâteaux
et donc des milliers de fois
mangé les deux,
jamais une seule fois on ne soit tombé
sur un cas où tous les deux étaient bons.
Ça aurait dû se produire dans au moins 9%
des cas, c'est imparable.
Et pourtant quand on a fait l'expérience,
on a trouvé ZÉRO.
Alors, où est l'erreur de logique,
comment c'est possible?
Eh bien, quand je fais mon petit
raisonnement
qui conduit à conclure qu'il doit y avoir
au moins 9% de paires
qui sont à la fois bonnes et contenant
du magnésium,
je fais sans m'en rendre compte une
hypothèse implicite.
Je suppose que le fait d'être bons ou mauvais
et de contenir ou pas du magnésium,
ce sont des propriétés intrinsèques
des gâteaux
qui existent indépendamment du fait
que je les mesure ou pas.
Un gâteau qui arrive au bout du tapis roulant
intrinsèquement,
soit il est bon soit il est mauvais,
soit il a du magnésium soit il n'en a pas,
peu importe le test qu'on va lui faire,
ses propriétés existent,
elles sont réelles.
Cette supposition implicite,
c'est ce qu'en physique on appelle
parfois "le réalisme".
C'est une hypothèse
très naturelle.
Repensez à ma pièce tirée
à pile ou face,
tant qu'elle est sous ma main
je ne connais pas son orientation
mais je pars du principe qu'elle en possède
réellement une,
indépendamment du fait que je retire
ma main ou pas pour la regarder.
Le réalisme c'est quelque chose de très
ancrée dans notre façon de penser
et c'est ce qui explique notre incrédulité
quand on entend parler pour la première
fois de superposition quantique.
Einstein disait d'ailleurs:
"est-ce que vous pensez que la lune cesse
d'exister quand on arrête de la regarder? "
De même on a envie de penser que le chat
est soit vivant soit mort
et que l'électron est forcément quelque part,
sa position existe,
c'est une propriété réelle qui lui est
intrinsèque,
indépendante du fait que
je le regarde ou pas.
Et donc ça, c'est ce que j'ai
implicitement supposé
dans mon raisonnement avec les gâteaux,
que leurs propriétés étaient réelles,
bien définies
indépendamment du fait qu'on les mesure
où pas,
sauf que si c'était vrai les résultats
d'expériences que je décris
seraient impossibles à obtenir.
Pourtant on les a vraiment obtenus,
alors pas avec des gâteaux,
mais avec des photons, et j'y reviendrai,
et les résultats de cette expérience
tendent donc à prouver
que l'idée que les objets aient
des propriétés réelles
qui existent indépendamment de
nos observations,
eh bien ça n'est pas si évident
pour des objets quantiques.
La réalité n'est peut-être pas si réelle
qu'on voudrait le penser,
ou en tout cas elle est différente,
car, quand on y réfléchit bien,
il y a tout de même une autre possibilité
qui permet d'expliquer ces résultats étonnants.
Imaginez que les gâteaux possèdent des
propriétés
réelles, intrinsèques, bien définies,
il existerait donc vraiment des
gâteaux
qui à la fois contiennent du magnésium
et sont bons dans 9 % des cas.
Mais supposons que lorsqu'un des opérateurs
décident de manger son gâteau,
le gâteau en question envoie un signal
perturbateur à l'autre gâteau,
de manière à le rendre mauvais,
je sais pas,
une sorte de vibration qui va le secouer
et ruiner son goût,
si ce genre de phénomène existait
ça permettrait d'expliquer
les résultats de l'expérience, le fait
qu'on n'ait jamais une paire de gâteaux
qui soient tous les deux bons,
alors qu'on trouve parfois des paires
de gâteaux ayant tous les deux du magnésium.
Le problème c'est que si on éloigne les
deux gâteaux suffisamment
et qu'on fait les mesures de façon
simultanée
et bien ça imposerait que cette hypothétique
perturbation voyage presque instantanément,
ce qui paraît assez bizarre.
Le fait que les objets ne puisse pas
s'influencer de façon instantanée à distance
c'est parfois ce qu'on appelle
"le critère de localité",
or toutes les théories physiques raisonnables
que l'on connaît
sont des théories locales qui respectent
ce critère.
Accepter que les résultats étranges
de l'expérience soient dus
à une influence instantanée à distance
entre les deux gâteaux,
ça voudrait dire renoncer à ce principe
de localité,
qui est un des fondements de la physique.
Pour bien voir, regardons comment on fait
l'expérience en vrai,
pas avec des gâteaux.
Dans la véritable expérience
on prend un cristal
qui, quand il est stimulé
d'une certaine façon,
émet des paires de photons
dans des directions opposées
et pour chacun des photons, on a
un dispositif de filtre polariseur
qui donne le choix entre mesurer
deux choses différentes.
Soit sa polarisation selon un certain
angle alpha
soit sa polarisation selon un autre
angle bêta.
On a un détecteur de photons derrière
chaque polariseur
et à chaque mesure la réponse
est binaire: - ou +
c'est-à-dire que: soit le photon
est absorbée par le filtre,
soit il passe et il est capté par
le détecteur, et ça de chaque côté.
Eh bien, avec certains réglages
particuliers de l'expérience
on obtient les résultats que j'ai présentés
avec les gâteaux.
Si on mesure de chaque côté les polarisations
selon des angles différents,
alors si c'est + sur alpha c'est
forcément + sur bêta.
Si on mesure des deux côtés selon alpha
alors dans 9 % des cas les deux sont +,
par contre jamais les deux ne sont
simultanément +
quand on mesure les deux selon la
polarisation bêta.
c'est exactement la même situation
qu'avec les gâteaux,
quand on mesure les deux selon alpha
et qu'on obtient + + dans 9 % des cas,
et bien si on avait au lieu de ça choisi
de les mesurer selon bêta
on aurait dû aussi logiquement
obtenir + +,
mais ça n'arrive jamais.
Donc soit on renonce à l'idée que les photons
possèdent des propriétés réelles
avant qu'on les mesure, soit on imagine que
l'un des photons, quand il se fait mesurer,
puisse envoyer un signal à l'autre qui le
modifie,
un signal qui voyage plus vite
que la lumière donc.
En conclusion, à cause de ce genre
d'expérience
on est obligé soit de renoncer
au réalisme,
au fait que les objets aient
des propriétés objectives
qui existent même si on
ne les mesure pas,
ce qui serait assez dingue
comme conclusion,
soit on doit renoncer au principe
de localité
et accepter que des trucs puissent
s'influencer instantanément à distance,
ce qui est presque aussi dingue,
puisque c'est quand même un des fondements
de la physique,
en particulier de la théorie de la
relativité.
Alors quand je vous raconte ça,
vous dites peut-être
que renoncer à l'un de ses principes
fondamentaux
sur la base d'une seule expérience,
c'est quand même un peu exagéré,
est-ce qu'on est sûr des résultats?
Eh bien oui, on est assez confiant et ce
pour deux raisons,
la première c'est qu'on a déjà fait
plusieurs autres expériences
qui montrent des résultats du même type,
et la deuxième c'est que
tous ces résultats
sont en fait des prédictions
de la mécanique quantique,
donc on s'attendait un peu à ce que
ça donne ça.
En fait toutes ces expériences relèvent
d'un phénomène plus général
découvert par le physicien John Bell
en 1964
et qu'on appelle la violation des
inégalités de Bell.
Les inégalités de Bell ce sont des
inégalités mathématiques
qui, en principe, limitent les résultats
possibles d'une expérience,
à partir du moment où on suppose que la
nature obéit aux principes de réalisme
et de localité, ce qu'on dénomme ensemble
le réalisme local.
Si le réalisme local est vrai
alors les inégalités de Bell sont
toujours respectées
et donc si une expérience a des résultats
qui sont en violation
des inégalités de Bell,
c'est que ses résultats devraient être
impossibles
à obtenir dans le cadre du réalisme local.
C'est ce qui se passe avec l'expérience
des gâteaux,
les inégalités de Bell nous disent qu'il
devrait y avoir forcément
au moins 9% de paires de bons gâteaux
et on n'en trouve aucune.
Les résultats de l'expérience ne respectent
pas les inégalités de Bell
et nous forcent à questionner l'hypothèse
du réalisme local.
Depuis les débats entre Schrödinger,
Einstein, Bohr, etc.
dans les années 1920-1930, la mécanique
quantique et les travaux de John Bell
nous ont permis d'imaginer et de réaliser
un certain nombre d'expériences
de ce genre.
Celle dont je vous ai parlé aujourd'hui
n'a pas été la première
et n'est vraiment pas la plus connue
mais je l'ai choisie parce qu'elle est,
il me semble,
la plus facile à vulgariser pour commencer
tant ces résultats sont frappants.
Mais la plus connue de toutes
ces expériences
de violation des inégalités de Bell,
c'est celle qui a été réalisée
à Orsay en 1982
par le physicien français
Alain Aspect
et je ferai bientôt un épisode dédié
à cette expérience
et à son importance historique.
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui,
en attendant si vous voulez plus de détails
sur ce que je vous ai raconté,
notamment pour ceux qui connaissent un peu
la mécanique quantique,
je vous renvoie au billet de blog qui
comme toujours accompagne la vidéo.
Abonnez-vous, mettez la cloche tout ça,
et on se retrouve prochainement
pour une nouvelle vidéo.
À bientôt
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -